the raids are seven and four against
toronto ryan yarbrough on the hill today
for the raise he has a streak of his own
against this blue jays ball club
helena flock to simian as you ever
missed with that cutter outside
runner goes 3-2 a little roller towards
short charged by walls tough play got
him there and up to second base goes
simeon
good take five line as that change up is
in the dirty small four second walk of
the inning
swinging at a miss throw down to first
got a chance he is out at first base
they pick off guerrero with joy putting
the tag on it
and the rays
retire toronto here at the top of the
first start number 14 for ross he's
coming off a no decision against the
same rays last time out pitched into the
sixth inning bottom of the first
first pitch and loud jumps all over it
high shot deep right and that baby's
gone
full run for brandon lau
on the first pitch offered by ross
crippling and the rays break out in
front one nothing
well that didn't take long
home run number 19 for brandon loud
one and two to diaz gets him bounced hip
held on to by jansen the strikeout for
[Applause]
popped out of play down the left side
long run for bow and that's going to be
caught
bow never gave up on it it looked like
meadows had conceded it was going to go
into the seats he just kind of took his
eye off it and bow came all the way over
from the shift made a nice running catch
in foul ground i wouldn't here two down
what a good change up that's the swing
of the miss strikeout so stripling
bounces back retires the next three in
order with a couple of strikeouts
g-man choi strikes out tried to check
his swing who went around
he is pitching
with a lot of purpose and a lot of
confidence as he went for the strikeout
came right back with a good fastball and
racks up another strike and that's three
in a row four in the ball game for ross
stripling
breaking ball hit on the ground but he
hasn't he'll step on the bag and the
inning is over
another good inning for ross stripling
he retires the side in order
drives this ball to right hip deep and
that's over the head of brandon loud one
hops off the fence and espinoza will get
to second base with a lead off double
he continues to come up with big hits
came up last year hit 267.
giving some playing time this year
there's a cut and miss jansen
is out on strikes strikeout number one
for yarbrough yeah and what yarbrough
needed right there he got that's an out
with out the you know the runner being
moved up
back to the top of the order marcus
simeone
swinging in drive deep to left field and
this ball is gonna go at two runs shot
for marcus simeon here's 22nd of the
season and just like that the blue jays
have the lead
full count
two gone
there he goes
swing and a miss springer
is out on strikes
two runs on the home run by simeon 2-1
toronto
well here's mike zenito to start the
home third
zanino hits one high and
defend gone
home run for mike cenino on a 1-0 pitch
and just like that the game is tied
cenino's 19th home run these two teams
playing long ball
ground ball shot into left
past espinal
kiermarn's going to dig for second he'll
make that easily
and rounds the back to throw
not a terribly good throw bounding back
in on a couple hops and caremeyer for a
moment
a little
stutter step toward third and decided to
hang on
at second with a double wonder how the
rays would respond to seeing their lead
go away man mike zemino with a great
response and now a chance to regain the
lead
there's one back into deep right field
that's gonna go
home run on a 3-2 pitch
brandon lau
double dump hits a second home run of
the day and this one will give the raise
the lead it's a 4-2 ball game
here's the 3-2
line drive that'll get down for a hit
might split the outfitters to go all the
way to the wall
guriel going the other way and drives
one up the alley for a two out double
one ball two strikes espinol swings and
misses strength three and yarbro works
around a single and a double
there's ball four the reigns will get
the lead off man on base
for the third time twice
they've had lead off home runs and now
lead off walk
got it fastball up and in strikes on
window fifth strikeout for
stripling
and there's ball four so he got ahead
but lost him and gives up the baits on
balls
and that'll probably do it for ross
stripling so charlie montoya
taking a long walk to the mound
and he's got anthony k ready in the
bullpen
[Applause]
[Music]
has room right near the foul ball makes
the catch ass kumar is retired to end
the inning
and he does
he got him boy three change-ups for
three strikes you know
that
you know may be part of the game plan
maybe not quite like that but that's
good recognition just understanding look
i've thrown this guy a number of these
pitches i get the same swing if i can
execute it and put it near that same
spot 2-2
in from right that's lau making the
catch
so one two three fifth inning through
four and a half four two tampa bay okay
i don't think you're getting a big jump
of them but we'll see
where it is not going the pitch taken
inside ball forward so back-to-back
walks
to start this fifth inning as lao moves
to second and richards the three teams
this season 22 games in total
another change if this is popped up
and left field curio coming in he'll get
there and makes the catch good job by
richards
boy he hits the outside corner with a
good heated right there and strikes out
taylor walls
another good fastball down and away for
the strike and that's three strikeouts
for richardson the four batters he's
faced
to put away zanino here boy what a pitch
right on the corner of 92. how about
richard striking out the side
that's a strike out there on the corner
how about that fish
wow
how about that sequence
fairbanks can't do it much better
shot to center field
garemeyer will be right there
three up three down in the eighth
a little soft liner that's gonna fall
into right a couple hops out to
hernandez
so the base hit for austin
right now a runner aboard nobody out and
jordan romano on for the 32nd time
into center field that's going to fall
and skip by kriechik
meadows will go to third they're going
gonna wave him around as the throw comes
into second
and the rays pick up another run
well save situation for diego castillo
on for the 33rd time
32 pitch
outside he walked him so castillo loses
guriel that'll push grichik down to
second two outs nothing in one to count
to him
the steal ready in the 01.
sends it into center field
kiermeier is right there and the rays
went this one
it's a 5-2 final yarbro is going to get
the win